christian schadeberg hat sich einen
großen wunsch erfüllt eine eigene
familie zusammen mit seinem partner und
einem befreundeten lesbischen paar der
kleine jahren zwei mütter und zwei väter
die beiden fahrer wohnen haus an haus in
berlin kennengelernt haben sich die
eltern im internet ein kinderwunsch gibt
es bei mir ich denke so seit anfang 20
also locker 15 jahre
für mich war das der einfachste weg ich
meine menschen lernen sich ständig über
online-plattformen kennen ob man freunde
sucht ob man ein date sucht ob man den
partner fürs leben sucht warum soll es
nicht in dieser form auch klappen
geklappt hat es mit der deutschen
website emily chip über 2300 menschen
suchen hier nach koh eltern die
anmeldung kostet einmalig rund 18 euro
im profil werden angaben zur gewünschten
familienkonstellation gemacht manche
wollen sich als eltern an der erziehung
beteiligen
andere eher im hintergrund bleiben wenn
alles passt wird das kind gezeugt mit
einer sperma probe und einem
plastikbecher
die eltern sind kein liebespaar sondern
freunde
deshalb heißt das konzept auch pope
rating christine wagner hat die seite
vor drei jahren gegründet und weiß
das internet macht die suche einfacher
ich glaube dass das dass das enorm
erleichtert und das ist vor allem auch
beschleunigt menschen kennenzulernen
weil so viel frauen zeigen dass
deutschland bis drei wochen ist man da
antworten bekommt und wie gesagt auch so
kinderwunsch gruppen auch das dann muss
natürlich der richtige gerade da sitzen
man hat einfach eine größere auswahl das
konzept stammt aus den usa
die größte website modelle wurde anfang
2011 gegründet inzwischen hat sie
mehrere zehntausend nutzer
80 prozent sind die heterosexuellen
viele von ihnen singles die nicht länger
ihren traumpartner suchen wollen 20
prozent sind lesbische und schwule
menschen
die website informiert auch über fragen
zur gesundheits checks oder sorgerechts
verträgen
ich glaube schon dass sich das zunehmend
entwickelt weil wir einfach alle so hoch
individualisiert zurzeit leben und jeder
so wie er seinen eigenen weg geht
unseren eigenen weg plant das eben
alternative konzepte und
individualisierte konzepte wo man
vielleicht mit unabhängiger ist zunehmen
werden
und so entstehen immer neue
familienformen mit nur einem elternteil
mehrere müttern oder vätern
doch was heißt das für die kinder
robert hagen ist familientherapeut und
beschäftigt sich mit patchwork familien
kinder brauchen sicherheit geborgenheit
die brauchen liebe zuwendung die
brauchen eine klare orientierung die
brauchen präsenz von eltern
wir brauchen belastbarkeit von
beziehungen
die dinge die gelten für alle für einen
älteren 234 die gleichen
herausforderungen also die andere
familien an farben trotzdem es gibt
kritik an den neuen familienmodelle
besonders konservative christen und
muslime sehen das wohl der kinder in
gefahr
im internet kämpfen sie gegen copa
rating familien und
gleichgeschlechtliche paare
denn sie fürchten dass deren kinder sich
nicht richtig entwickeln zu
irgendwelchen verhaltensauffälligkeiten
oder entwicklungsrisiken oder
entwicklungsstörungen
auch gibt es überhaupt keinen
wissenschaftlichen zusammenhang dass das
sind ganz ganz andere wirkung verformen
die da zu veranschlagen sind deshalb
überhaupt nichts mit der
familienkonstellation es gibt in unserem
bekanntenkreis durchaus mehr pro partner
informieren und es gibt es schwule väter
die kinder haben und ich glaube diese
kinder also alle kinder die ich kenne
sind glücklich ich glaube dass das
wichtigste dabei
christian und seine familie haben
bislang keine negativen erfahrungen
gemacht
ihr familienmodell ist in ihrem umfeld
akzeptiert und hat sich bewährt so sehr
dass bald noch ein weiteres können dazu
kommen soll